yeah okay good party here mom and call
it I'm gonna call it in yeah right can't
live without it tails you lose
Nolan will you tell these two gentlemen
are it's time for me to go my fate
decided by the flip of a coin how much
longer must I that's a clip from the
from she's gotta have it the 1986 movie
that marked the feature-length debut of
director Spike Lee Lee followed it up
with a string of landmark movies
including do the right thing which
earned him an Oscar nomination for Best
Screenplay 31 years later his career has
come full circle
on Thursday Netflix premiered the
television series she's got to have it
which reimagines the original story and
sets it in 2017 it is as timely as ever
we spoke with Lee this week at his
offices in Brooklyn New York
I consider myself abnormal but who wants
to be like everybody else
she's got to have it tells the story of
a polyamorous black female artist who is
juggling for different lovers in the
recently gentrified neighborhood of Fort
Greene Brooklyn
darling do you worry one day that the
Brooklyn that is chronicled in your
films won't exist anymore the four green
in bed stars and she's gonna have the
film was no more today the neighborhood
where Lee grew up and said his story is
much different both on screen and off
you said the television afforded you
more of a canvas
yes a bigger cat eyes but and a lot more
money to buy more paint so we had good
we have more coloring yeah you weren't
doing it
pun intended black and white
[Music]
li was 29 and just out of NYU film
school when he released she's got a have
it sold the summer 1985 he shot she's
gonna have it in 12 days July 1st July
14 to six day weeks
my grandmother's Emmy reat the Shelton
gave me the seed money really so went on
to make seven seven thousand million
dollars and uh did you tell your
grandmother what the film was gonna be
about my granddad complete faith in me
she says spikey I know nothing about
filmmaking but that's what you want to
do I was a poor shoot the movie explores
themes of sexuality and empowerment
through the character of a young artist
named NOLA darling
I consider myself normal whatever that
means I knew that Nolan dalla would be a
woman that people talk about does it
surprise you looking back at the film
how risky it was nobody knows this we
were having trouble with the rating
system because it was just too much
thought I black all those making black
people black bodies on the screen and so
they would tell us there's too much sex
I'd the day we opened I got a call from
the MPAA
saying had to make a cut and I said the
film was playing Lee called his editor
Barry Brown and sent him to the theater
to cut half of the scene while the film
was still playing the projection is look
sentences so what do you do so I know
that there's a moment where they part
and then they're gonna come back
together cut there get to the end of the
scene right again
and what was a remarkable was it went
right through that movie that set in
motion the rest of the partnership she's
got a habit yeah oh she's got to have it
did everything but this doesn't seem
think we would have careers without it
you're a complicated puzzle ah yeah I
like your curiosity I like yours too is
that right this time around we made sure
to include female perspective in
developing the
episode first season career you are the
epitome of narcissism don't you get
tired of you never happened he enlisted
his wife Tonya Lewis Lee whom he credits
with bringing the story to TV as well as
five female writers including the
Pulitzer prize-winning playwright Lynn
Nottage you were criticized by some
prominent feminists
that NOLA darling in the film version
was this is the male gaze that directed
this film people forget that this is my
first film people forget this you could
have was 86 minutes long people get that
we've business we will revisit this 30
years
ladies thirty years ago I was not
married 30 years ago I was not a father
so it's not a big thing to include black
women in sprin this project is about
black women is what you need just my
mother right here Lee credits his late
mother an elementary school teacher with
his love for cinema Godfather in a town
called El Padrino artifacts of which are
on display throughout his offices this
is Italian poster Martin Scorsese's mean
streets signed by Marty but the
oscar-winning director says despite his
success there is still a long way to go
for people of color and women looking to
make it in Hollywood
you hear that pal Harriet Tubman just
shot herself with a pistol from the
grave whoa this is only gonna change
when we get in the room with the
gatekeepers the gatekeepers are unstuff
mm-hmm at CBS at NBC and Warner Brothers
and Netflix as joked however it is
Amazon and they have meetings about what
we're making I mean it's my meeting
about this show all right where's spike
gonna go there doesn't mean it made to
get me on the show these are the
gatekeepers that make these decisions
and until were in those rooms
with a gatekeeper says nothing - no
changing isn't freedom also having the
right to do whatever you will with your
own body bait you Michelle Obama isn't
about to start carving herself up
anytime soon nope
li got a second chance to reimagine NOLA
darling at precisely the moment when
gender and sexuality are making national
headlines we're having this huge
reckoning when it comes to women women
being in the room women having power
women making decisions women as victims
when you when you think about what's
going on in the national conversation
and you think about this show that's
about to premiere what's the lesson I'm
gonna give you an honest answer okay I
don't tell Isis what the lesson is I
respect my audience
I never say well you come on it theater
here the thing the takeaways I'm gonna
do takeaways I leave it up to the oiz I
respect their intelligence what do you
think about the conversation we're
having given that you don't overdo um he
is a master of cinema it's fascinating
how timely the themes if she's got to
have it made in 1986 are today in 27
what a cool office huh yes also the
coolest office maybe in America and did
I hear that correctly his grandmother
called him spikey yes yes I did not call
him spike now you can second interview
Alex it's a great piece